[Music]
the final push for votes
as politicians campaign ahead of
Sunday's parliamentary elections in
Benin
and for many voters they're excited
about the prospect of restoring
confidence in the country's democracy
the last legislative election in 2019
sparked clashes that left several people
dead after the opposition party was
banned from participating
that year only two political parties
supporting president Patrice Stallone
were allowed
a constitutional Court ruling last
November gave a green light to the
opposition now they have a position
parties I think at least we have to
Democrat and MPL
which are clear opposition parties I
think first of all people could come out
for because they have those parties that
are there
Any Corner
show about opposition
opposite to their political rights
they've been excluded from the ballot
since 29. and want to win a majority in
Parliament to change laws they consider
repressed but Sunday's vote is more than
just the election of parliament members
the results will determine who runs for
president in 2026. the Electoral code
requires any candidate for president to
get endorsement from legislators and
Mayors in order to run
a political party can only get
representation in Parliament if it gets
10 percent of the total votes cast
Nationwide regardless of whether it wins
the constituency
the election commission says it's ready
we started distribution of election
materials from the furthest to the
Region's nearest to Cottonwood now all
areas have received the needed election
materials
voters here hoping this election will
restore opposition politics in Benin and
that the country will avoid violent
clashes of 2019.
observers will be watching not only the
conduct but also the outcome of this
election
it will determine whether or not the
streets are calm Ahmad Idris al-jazeera